good morning how are you dan I'm
terrific I understand you got a birthday
coming up here a big one as I here yes
yes I do know that's coming up as I've
been the topic of much conversation
amongst the danettes as to what to get
dan for is a big birthday the 40th
birthdays aren't that big Rick so you
know we think we discussed agree but
60th are yeah that's true yeah I you
know what I'll just take condolences you
know you don't have to get me anything
just condolences I don't tell me these
both of these quarterbacks at the top
can't be great right I think if the odds
are that one is going to be and one is
not is that the way his you know gonna
proven that's what that's what history
tells us yeah uh you know I think this
kid Jared Goff is really special i saw
him as a true freshman and he just got
this innate ability throw people open
and people say that all the time but you
have to have kind of a sense about where
to shape a ball just like great pitchers
know how to shade a plate and he's got
that ability and he's got it whether he
has to move in the pocket and but he has
to shuffle and avoid pressure he just
has the ability to put the ball where
only his guy can catch it and i think
that's a special trait something that
you really have a difficult time
teaching either have it or you don't and
I think he's going to have a fabulous
career monster with the Los Angeles Rams
cos they've got a lot of the pieces
already in place namely Todd Gurley to
hand off to and with the left kid yeah
the thing about him he's kind of like a
unicorn you know he just kind of
happened it came to the combine
everybody looked he was bigger stronger
faster and then when you find out and do
the due diligence he's also smarter he
didn't even ever get a be at North
Dakota State so there's a lot to like
about him but we have to wait and see
whether or not he can see things and
that responds to his arm and his feet to
throw accurately at the NFL level
because he's never seen that kind of
speed right before we get to the second
or third round quarterback selections
let me ask you as a former college coach
the Laremy Tunsil situation here if your
old master okay did
Hugh Freeze have a good night as the old
Miss head coach the three players
drafted in the first round that was a
nightmare of epic proportions and I like
you he was a buddy of mine that was an
absolute nightmare I thought I was
watching Silence of the lamp I mean I'm
going is this real is this really
happening you get this desk pass I read
and then also he takes it off in there
he is any uh he manned up to it I mean
he admitted that it was him and his a
long time ago and then all of a sudden
off the cuff oh yeah and I took money
from one of the coaches at Ole Miss it
could not have been worse for Ole Miss
but let's say you're right go back to
Rick three guys are taking in the first
draft round let's say you're in the war
room and you're the Ravens and you're
the head coach can you can you look past
that on draft night you know it kinda
comes down to where you are as an
organization and had you have have you
had good luck with those guys who've
been on you know on the line in terms of
character if your Arizona and you've had
around Matthew come in and do all the
great things that have happened for that
young man despite some some flaws while
in college then you can go ahead and
take chem dici you got it you got a free
pass because things have gone well for
you there when you're uh the Raven and
you've had some some wrongdoers that
have been really public wrongdoers the
safer choice right there is Ronnie
Stanley his mannion who knows that they
didn't have him ranked higher there were
some people that had him ranked higher
but as you go up that uh that list you
you either have a free pass to take a
guy because of his talent look past the
character flaw or you don't and that
becomes an organizational decision and
it put a lot of gm's in that five to 13
range in a quandary namely Jerry Reese
with the Giants because both his guys
were gone right yes Lloyd was gone and
and uh Jack Conkling were gone and there
was no one to trade back with just crazy
crazy I in and I think that it's
unfolding right in front of you it's
hard to say to your owner hey but he's a
really
good player yeah don't you took money in
college and he's got a bong mask on but
aside from that though he's miserable
than that yeah he's a terrific yeah
we're gonna build our team around him
mm-hmm he's got great feet yeah yeah you
got cranky he's it in Paris all right
give me the quarterback you love who's
still available I I think Christian
Hackenberg will be the next one off the
board you know Jerry dinardo's a close
friend of mine works for the Big Ten
Network and he saw him live and in Perth
in person as a freshman and told me this
is the best freshman quarterback you'd
ever seen and you know had him pegged to
be the first guy of the NFL Draft when
the time came about obviously that the
James Franklin uh experiment for her
Christian Hackenberg didn't go well but
you can't blame a guy who's been sacked
83 times 10 times in this opening game
this year against temple you get hard to
play quarterback when you're on your
back but the guy has all the stuff I
think he people got a little shy away
when Bill O'Brien went and and sign
Brock Osweiler rather than waiting and
drafting his former quarterback from
penn state but i think he's the next
Connor cook could be the next guy given
his stature and his ability to win games
my favorite guy still on the board that
will probably be a little later is Kevin
Hogan out of Stanford I just think he's
a winner finds ways to make blaze
whether it be with his arm and his legs
there's no situation too big for him and
when you're taking Stanford 23 Rose
Bowls there's something good about you
who had a worst night Laremy Tunsil or
miles genic well Myles Jack I mean
Laremy Tunsil made the bet that he's in
right Myles Jack this is just really
really sad and this gets back to my my
situate might might request of the NCAA
in pro football that there's be an
opportunity for people to take their
name out of the Hat and go back to
college you know it shouldn't all the
risk shouldn't be on kids I assume that
Myles jack will go quickly today and I'm
assuming that there was a insurance
policy that will protect him from this
free fall but you know when the news of
his knee and
and the ticking time bomb quote unquote
uh I it you knew that it was going to be
damaging you didn't realize he'd fall
all the way out of the first round
because just on talent dan he's a top
five guy yeah he's a good kid too you
know it's a great kid yeah and he was
too forthcoming he gave the information
he's going to need microfracture surgery
uh Derrick Henry does he hear his name
today tonight second row wouldn't
wouldn't shock me uh that we hear his
name very quickly I wouldn't be
surprised for someone to trade up to get
Derrick Henry you know say what you will
about is upright running style and this
you know stiff hips as some have
evaluated the guy is a battering ram
when you run for you know 90 carries in
two games 46 and 44 at the end of the
year when they need you most there's
something special about you and and I
think Henry will be gone here early as
is the case probably with a lot of
Alabama guys I think another shocker was
only one alabama guy in the first round
in their Center Kelly Ryan Kelly 18 to
the Colts I know you're working i
appreciate you taking time out hopefully
we'll cross spanish here soon thank you
Rick happy birthday dad thank you buddy
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience